voilà le genre d'accueil qui pourrait
devenir la norme dans beaucoup
d'entreprises une caméra thermique
capable de lire votre température en
moins d'une seconde
et ce n'est pas tout j'arrive au bureau
ce matin je prends ma température par le
biais de cette caméra qui détecte
également le port du masque si tout va
bien je peux aller bosser
sinon à mails seront envoyés dès demain
ma pdg pour la bureautique
j'ai des températures que je pourrais
pas venir travailler aujourd'hui votre
métier votre s'il vous plaît cette
démonstration nous est proposé dans les
locaux d'un groupe spécialisé jusqu
alors dans les écrans tactiles
le responsable commercial assure sans
sourciller que ce système pourrait être
couplé à l'ouverture d'un sas pas de
fièvre masques portés ont déclenché
l'ouverture de la banque qui est
derrière tout simplement voilà il ya
beaucoup d'applicatifs qui sont
possibles avec ce type d'appareil à ce
jour 152,7 aux thèmes ont été vendus à
travers le monde
la directrice de l'entreprise estime le
marché quasiment sans limite
on a les boutiques les magasins on a
aussi les enceintes sportives
les municipalités en ce moment on a déjà
conclu des contrats avec ce type de
thiais dans des lycées ce que
l'entreprise ne dit pas c'est qu'en juin
dernier le conseil d'état a demandé à
une commune parisienne de retirer
plusieurs caméras thermiques installés
dans des écoles dans le cadre du cosy d'
au motif que la collectivité pourrait
porter atteinte à la vie privée des
élèves et du personnel des
questionnements qui s'appliqueront
bientôt aussi aux entreprises et aux
salariés